JOHN: TODAY PRESIDENT OBAMA AND
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN WENT TO
ORLANDO TO PAY RESPECTS TO THE
VICTIMS OF THE NIGHTCLUB
SHOOTING.
IT WAS A SCENE OF BIPARTISANSHIP
AS PRESIDENT OBAMA EXITED AIR
FORCE ONE WITH MARCO RUBIO AND
COUNCILMAN COREY GRAHAM.
PRESIDENT OBAMA: THEY ARE OUR
FAMILY.
THEY ARE PART OF THE AMERICAN
TODAY THE VICE PRESIDENT AND I
TOLD THEM ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT OUR HEARTS
ARE BROKEN, TOO.
JOHN: BACK IN WASHINGTON, THE
FIGHT OVER GUN-CONTROL CONTINUES
.
AFTER A 15-HOUR SYLVESTER
DEMOCRATS STAGED ON THE SENATE
FLOOR YESTERDAY SEEMED TO HAVE
WORKED.
THE AMENDMENTS, WHICH WILL
LIKELY BE VOTED ON MONDAY, WHAT
EXTENT BACK ON CHECKS AND ARE
SUSPECTED TERRORISTS FROM
PURCHASING FIREARMS.
SOME REPUBLICANS IN A TOUGH
PLACE -- ROB PORTMAN OF OHIO,
KELLY AYOTTE OF MANAGER, AND PAT
TOOMEY OF PENNSYLVANIA -- HAVE
INDICATED A WILLINGNESS TO
COMPROMISE.
GIVEN THE FACT THAT THE
DEMOCRATS ARE IN THIS UNUSUAL
CIRCUMSTANCE, PRESENTED NOMINEE
IN HILLARY CLINTON WHO IS
CLEARLY GOING TO MAKE
GUN-CONTROL BIG PART OF HER
CAMPAIGN AT THE PRESIDENTIAL
LEVEL IN A WAY THAT NO NOMINEE
HAS IN A LONG TIME, WHAT DO YOU
THINK OF WHAT WE'VE SEEN FROM
HER AND HOW THINGS ARE SHIFTING
AROUND THIS WEEK, WHAT DO YOU
THINK THIS PORTENDS FOR DOWN
BALLOT RACES, SENATE RACES,
HOUSE RACES, FOR THE GUN-CONTROL
DEBATE?
WHAT EFFECT MIGHT IT HAVE IN
THOSE RACES?
ALEX: I THINK WE HAVE ALREADY
SEEN AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
CONCERTED COORDINATION BETWEEN
THE UPPER LEVELS OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ANY FOOT
SOLDIERS ON TRIAL.
I THINK YOU WILL -- AND THE FOOT
SOLDIERS ON TRUCK.
AS MUCH AS YOU SAY THIS IS A
STORY THAT KEEPS HAPPENING, THE
UMPTEENTH TIME THE PRESIDENT HAS
HAD TO EULOGIZE THE VICTIMS AND
FAMILIES, THIS FEELS DIFFERENT,
BECAUSE OF A BROAD SENSE OF
FRUSTRATION AROUND GUN SAFETY
REFORM DID -- SAFETY REFORM.
THIS HAS ALWAYS BEEN A POLITICAL
ISSUE BUT IT WILL BE VERY MUCH A
CAMPAIGN ISSUE IN A COORDINATED
FASHION THROUGH THE END OF THE
YEAR.
JOHN: ONE OF THE THINGS THAT HAS
REALLY CHANGED HERE -- HILLARY
CLINTON HAS CLEARLY DETECTED NOT
JUST IN THE DEMOCRATIC
NOMINATION FIGHT BUT ALSO UP
GENERAL ELECTION LEVEL, THAT SHE
THINKS THAT GUN-CONTROL IS A
WINNING ISSUE FOR HER.
THAT IS A BIG CHANGE.
THE OTHER THING THAT HAS CHANGED
AND I THINK ORLANDO HAS CHANGED
IN A SPECIFIC WAY, NOW THE
QUESTION OF WHEN CONTROL IS
LINKED TO TERRORISM IN A WAY IT
HAS NEVER BEEN BEFORE.
IT STARTED WITH SAN BERNARDINO,
BUT THIS IS THE NEW THING.
ONE DOESN'T EVER LIKE TO TALK
ABOUT WHO WINS OR LOSES
POLITICALLY FROM THESE HORRIBLE
ATROCITIES.
BUT IN THIS CASE, IF YOU ARE FOR
GUN-CONTROL, THE EXTRA ARGUMENT
THAT, HEY, IF YOU ARE AGAINST
GUN CONTROL YOU ARE ON THE
TERRORISTS.
IT BECOMES ANOTHER CARD THAT CAN
BE PLAYED.
I THINK DEMOCRATS IN PLACES LIKE
PENNSYLVANIA, OHIO, NEW
HAMPSHIRE, MAYBE EVEN ARIZONA
WHERE JOHN MCCAIN RACE, I TAKE A
LOT OF THE DEMOCRATIC SENATORS
WILL START TO MAKE THIS ARGUMENT
AND PUT THOSE REPUBLICANS IN A
DIFFICULT POSITION IF THEY ARE
NOT GOING TO AT LEAST MAKE SOME
NODS TOWARDS BEING ABLE TO TALK
ABOUT -- MAKE SOME NODS AS FAR
AS CHANGING THE LAWS, AT LEAST
FOR SOMETHING LIKE ALLOWING
PEOPLE -- THE PEOPLE WEAPONS WHO
HAVE BEEN ON THE NO-FLY LIST.
ALEX: SURE, AND YOU ARE RIGHT TO
NOTE THAT THIS CONFLATES TWO
ISSUES.
THE OTHER ISSUE IT CONFLATES IS
GAY-RIGHTS AND THE LGBT MOVEMENT
HAS BEEN POWERFUL AND EFFECTIVE
NOT JUST LOBBYING EFFICACY IN
AMERICAN POLITICS.
THEY ARE FIRED UP ABOUT THIS
ISSUE.
IT ADDS A THIRD, TRIANGULATED
DYNAMIC TO THIS BIT ONE THAT
DOES NOT PLAY AS WELL DOWN
BALLOT BUT YOU COULD TALK ABOUT
THE NATIONAL RACE, ANOTHER
REASON FOR HILLARY CLINTON TO
WRAP HER ARMS AROUND THE ISSUE
IN ORLANDO IN PARTICULAR, THAT
CERTAINLY IS A DECIDING FACTOR.
JOHN: HAVE ALL BECOME, WITH GOOD
REASON, SKEPTICAL TO THE POINT
OF CYNICAL ABOUT THE ABILITY FOR
THE GUN CONTROL DEBATE TO CHANGE
BECAUSE THE POWER OF THE NRA.
WE SAW AFTER SANDY HOOK THERE
WAS SO MUCH EFFORT PUT INTO
CHANGING THE GUN LAWS, SO MUCH
CONCERTED ACTION ON PART OF THE
PRESIDENT AND VICE PRESIDENT,
EVERYBODY.
AND YET NOTHING HAPPENED.
I THINK TO GO BACK TO THIS FIRST
POINT, THIS IS A DIFFERENT
MOMENT AND IT IS DIFFERENT
PRECISELY BECAUSE OF THE SCALE
OF THE ATROCITIES SO GREAT,
GREATEST MASS SHOOTING IN
AMERICAN HISTORY, AND THERE IS
THIS OTHER ELEMENT WHEN THERE IS
A JUJITSU THINK THE DEMOCRATS
CAN DO BECAUSE OF THE LINK TO
TERRORISM.
ESPECIALLY THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN,
ESPECIALLY IF THE COMPOSITION OF
THE SENATE AND HOUSE CHANGE, WE
COULD FINALLY BE THERE WERE AT
LEAST SOME MODEST GUN CONTROL
COULD ACTUALLY HAPPEN.
PROBABLY NOT NEXT WEEK OR THE
WEEK AFTER, BUT MAYBE A YEAR
FROM NOW?
ALEX: SPEAKING OF HILLARY
CLINTON, SHE ROLLED OUT HER
FIRST TV AD OF THE GENERAL
ELECTION SEASON WITH SPOTS ON
THE AIR IN 18 GENERAL ELECTION
STATES RANGING FROM DIVINE AND A
NEW HAMPSHIRE TO FLORIDA AND
OHIO.
BOTH ADS ARE PART OF A $7
MILLION BUY OVER THE NEXT SIX
WEEKS AND FOCUS PRIMARILY ON
CLINTON'S BIOGRAPHY, ESPECIALLY
FOR ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES.
HERE IS ONE THAT TAKES A LOOK AT
HER TENURE AS FIRST LADY DECADES
AGO.
>> FOR HILLARY, IT HAS ALWAYS
BEEN ABOUT KIDS, AND WHEN
MILLIONS COULDN'T GET HEALTH
CARE, THIS FIRST LADY WORKED
WITH REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS
TO FIX IT, CREATING THE
CHILDREN'S HEALTH INSURANCE
PROGRAM.
>> SO THAT EVERY CHILD GETS THE
HEALTH CARE THAT CHILD DESERVES
TO HAVE.
>> NOW 8 MILLION KIDS ARE
COVERED.
THAT IS THE KIND OF LEADER SHE
IS IN THE KIND OF PRESIDENT SHE
WILL BE.
ALEX: HERE IS ANOTHER AD ABOUT
CLINTON'S MORE RECENT
INTERNATIONAL WORK.
BEEN CHALLENGES, SHESTATE -
STOOD UP FOR AMERICAN VALUES
AROUND THE WORLD, WORKING TO END
THE TRAFFICKING OF WOMEN AND
GIRLS.
THROUGH THE YEARS THERE HAVE
IS NOT A VERY POPUL
IN THE COUNTRY.
TRU AND I THINK THERE IS
DEFINITELY AN ATTEMPT TO WIDEN
THE GENDER GAP AND CAPITALIZE ON
THAT.
THE OTHER THING THAT IS TRUE IS
THAT DONALD TRUMP'S NEGATIVES
ARE SO HIGH IT IS HARD TO
IMAGINE THEM BEING MUCH HIGHER
THAN THEY ARE.
WHEN YOU'RE UNFAVORABLES ARE 70%
AND YOU ARE IN THE TROUBLE HE IS
IN, THE REASON YOU DO NEGATIVE
ADS IS TO DRIVE UP THE OTHER
CANDIDATES UNFAVORABLES.
THESE ARE ALMOST AT THE
THEORETICAL LIMIT.
THERE ARE AT LEAST 30% OF
HARD-CORE REPUBLICANS WHO WILL
VOTE FOR TRUMP NO MATTER WHAT.
ARE YOU GOING TO SPEND MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS TO PUSH UP THE GUYS
NEGATIVES?
ALEX: IT'S DONE.
JOHN: DONE FOR NOW AND IT WAS
MORE WORK TO DO ON THE SIDE.
ALEX: THERE IS A CONCERTED AD
BUY ACROSS MAJOR MARKETS AND IT
IS A MESSAGE YOU WOULD NEVER SEE
FROM THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
YOU ARE STRUCK BY THE
CONTRASTING CAMPAIGN STYLES AND
POSSIBILITIES.
IT IS HARD TO IMAGINE THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN RELEASING AN ANALOG AD.
JOHN: VIRGINIA, $1.6 MILLION.
OHIO, $1.3 MILLION.
IOWA, UNDER $1 MILLION, BUT
STILL BIG NUMBERS.
FLORIDA, NORTH CAROLINA, NEVADA,
$7 MILLION IN TOTAL.
YOU KNOW HOW THAT IS MATCHED IN
-- BY THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN IN
THOSE STATES?
NIL, ZERO.
THIS DISPARITY, CANNOT GET HIM
NOT BEING ON THE AIR IN
BATTLEGROUND STATES, COULD HARM
HIM SEVERELY BY THE END OF THE
AUCTION BID COMING UP, MORE ON
THE PRESIDENT'S TRIP TO ORLANDO
AND WE WILL TALK TO BERNIE
SANDERS' CAMPAIGN MANAGER JEFF
WEAVER.
♪ ♪
PRESIDENT OBAMA: NOW, IF WE ARE
HONEST WITH OURSELVES, IF IN
FACT WE WANT TO SHOW THE BEST OF
OUR HUMANITY, THEN WE ARE ALL
GOING TO HAVE TO WORK TOGETHER
AT EVERY LEVEL OF GOVERNMENT,
ACROSS POLITICAL LINES, AND DO
MORE TO STOP KILLERS WHO WANT TO
TERRORIZE US.
JOHN: WELCOME BACK.
THAT WAS MORE FOR PRESIDENT
OBAMA'S REMARKS TODAY IN
ORLANDO, WHERE HE MET WITH
FAMILIES OF THE VICTIMS OF
SUNDAY'S SHOOTING.
WE HAVE SEEN PRESIDENT OBAMA IN
THIS SETTING SO MANY TIMES NOW,
TRAGICALLY, OBVIOUSLY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT IS
GOING THROUGH HIS MIND NOW?
OMINOUSLY, THERE IS A GREAT
SENSE OF SADNESS AND FRUSTRATION
THAT ON THIS ISSUE, WHAT -- WHEN
HE HAS TO GO INTO THIS AGAIN,
WHAT KIND OF PSYCHIC TOLL DO YOU
THINK THAT TAKES ON A PRESIDENT?
PRESIDENT?
ALEX: THIS PRESIDENT SAID THE
HARDEST DAY OF HIS PRESIDENCY IS
WHEN HE HAD TO MEET WITH THE
FAMILIES OF THE NEW TOWN
SHOOTING.
THERE HAVE BEEN A LOT OF OUR
DAYS IN HIS PRESIDENCY.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE PSYCHIC
TOLL, THESE ARE THE MOST TRYING
TIMES FOR THIS PRESIDENT, GOING
IN THE ROOM, AS HE ALWAYS DOES,
TO MEET WITH FAMILIES AND TALK
ABOUT THEIR DEAD CHILDREN, WHICH
IS NOT A TEST ANY PRESIDENT
WANTS TO DO.
THE SHEER NUMBER OF TIMES HE HAS
HAD TO DO IT IS TRAGIC IN
ITSELF.
THIS MOMENT IS PROBABLY
DIFFERENT IN THAT HE IS LOOKING
AT THE REST OF HIS PRESIDENCY
AND IS FAIRLY RESIGNED TO THE
FACT THAT NOTHING REAL IS LIKELY
TO HAPPEN ON THE NATIONAL LEVEL
WHEN IT COMES TO GUN SAFETY.
AND THEN A  -- THAT IS CAUSE
FOR NOT JUST FRUSTRATION FOR
PROBABLY SOME MEASURE OF ANGER.
JOHN: WHEN MARK AND I WROTE
"DOUBLE DOWN" WE TALKED ABOUT
THIS MOMENT AS HE WAS GETTING
READY TO RUN FOR REELECTION IN
2012 AND TALK TO HIS AIDES AND
STUFF THAT HE FELT BAD ABOUT,
WAS SELF CRITICAL, ISSUES THAT
HE HAD NOT DONE ENOUGH, IN HIS
JUDGMENT, ON IN THE FIRST TERM,
STUFF LIKE CLIMATE CHANGE AND
GLOBAL WARMING, SAME-SEX
MARRIAGE.
ANOTHER WAS GUN CONTROL.
HE WAS ABLE IN THE SECOND TERM
TO MOVE THE BALL OR AT LEAST
COME TO THE POSITION THAT HE
GENUINELY BELIEVE ON MANY OF
THOSE ISSUES.
FOR INSTANCE, CLIMATE CHANGE,
WHERE HE GOT THE CLIMATE DEAL
DONE.
SAME-SEX MARRIAGE, WHERE HE CAME
AROUND EVENTUALLY BEFORE THE END
OF 2012.
I THINK IN SOME WAYS THIS IS NOT
JUST FRUSTRATING FOR HIM, BUT HE
WILL AFFECT THAT THIS WAS THE
ONE ISSUE, GUN CONTROL, THAT IN
HIS FIRST FOUR YEARS, HE MAY NOT
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DO ANYTHING
ABOUT IT, BUT IT WAS A PLACE
THAT HE GENUINELY BELIEVED HE
DIDN'T REALLY CAMPAIGN ON IN
2008 AND DIDN'T TRY TO DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IN THE FIRST FOUR
YEARS.
OBVIOUSLY, THAT HAS CHANGED
AFTER SANDY HOOK.
BUT IT IS STILL SOMETHING HE
WILL KIND OF REGRET HOW HE
HANDLED IT.
ALEX: YEAH, AND IF YOU TALK
ABOUT THE DIVORCE AND THE
SADNESS HE FEELS, THERE IS
CERTAINLY THE ISSUE, BUT THERE
IS ALSO THE DYNAMIC OF PARENTS
WHO HAVE LOST THEIR CHILDREN.
HE WAS IN ORLANDO TODAY WITH JOE
BIDEN AND IT WAS NOTED BY SOME
IN THE PRESS THAT THERE WAS MORE
OF AN EMOTIONAL CONTACT BETWEEN
THE PRESIDENT AND VICE PRESIDENT
, AND UNDERSTANDABLY SO, GIVEN
THE FACT THAT JOE BIDEN HAS OF
COURSE LOST HIS OWN SON.
JOHN: LET'S GO QUICK TO CHRIS
JENSEN -- CHRIS JANSING, NBC
SENIOR WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENT.
GIVE US A SENSE OF WHAT THIS DAY
WAS LIKE FROM WHAT IT IS LIKE ON
THE GROUND THERE.
CHRIS: I THINK ALEX'S POINT, THE
PRESIDENT SPOKE FOR 17 MINUTES
AFTER MEETING WITH THE FAMILIES,
HE SAID THEIR GRIEF IS BEYOND
DESCRIPTION.
HE TALKED ABOUT THE FATHER OF AN
18-YEAR-OLD GIRL AND WHAT A
BRIGHT FUTURE SHE HAD IT YOU CAN
JUST IMAGINE FOR JOE BIDEN AS
WELL WHO LOST HIS OWN SON BEAU,
SO CLOSE TO HIM.
BUT VERY QUICKLY, AFTER TALKING
ABOUT WHAT THIS HAS MEANT, WE
ARE ALL PART OF THIS FAMILY, HE
TURNED TO THE POLITICS OF IT.
HE SAID MANY OF THESE FAMILY
MEMBERS WERE PLEADING WITH HIM
TO GET SOMETHING DONE AND SEE
THAT THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN
AND YOU HAVE IT IN A SITUATION
WHERE CLEARLY, AS YOU POINTED
OUT, HE HAS BEEN FRUSTRATING,
ESPECIALLY IN THE AFTERMATH OF
NEW TOWN.
WE SAW HIM EMOTIONAL JUST A
COUPLE DAYS AGO THAT SOME OF
THESE LEGISLATIVE INITIATIVES
HAVE DIED, AND NOW THEY ARE BACK
IN THE FOREFRONT IN THE MIDDLE
OF A HOTLY CONTESTED POLITICAL
SEASON.
HE HAS SIX MONTHS LEFT.
HE ALSO HAS HIGH APPROVAL
RATINGS.
AND HE FOUND IT NOT JUST
FRUSTRATING BUT THAT SHE SOUNDED
NOT JUST FRUSTRATED BUT
DETERMINED, CLEARLY WALKING THAT
LINE OF POLITICAL LEADER BUT
ALSO CONSOLER IN CHIEF.
JOHN: CHRIS, WE HAVE ABOUT 20
SECONDS.
DOES THE WHITE HOUSE THINK THERE
IS ANY CHANCE SOMETHING WILL
MOVE ON CAPITOL HILL ON THIS
ISSUE OR ARE THEY RESIGN?
CHRIS: I THINK WHEN YOU TALK TO
THEM AND ARE HONEST MOMENTS,
THEY DON'T GIVE IT A WHOLE LOT
OF CHANCE.
BUT I WILL SAY THAT I SPOKE TO
THE DATA OF ONE OF THE VICTIMS
IN COLUMBINE WHO PULLED ME THAT
AFTER SAN BERNADINO, YOU WILL AT
SOME POINT INSTEAD OF WEARINESS
30'S ACCUMULATIVE AFFECT OF
PEOPLE JUST -- THERE IS
ACCUMULATIVE EFFECT OF PEOPLE
JUST SAYING ENOUGH.
THERE IS ANY HOPE THAT THEY FEEL
LIKE IT HAS HAD TO HAPPEN
QUICKLY.
JOHN: CHRIS JANSING, THANK YOU.
COMING UP, BERNIE SANDERS
CAMPAIGN MANAGER JEFF WEAVER.
♪
JOHN: TONIGHT BERNIE SANDERS IS
DELIVERING AN ONLINE VIDEO
ADDRESS HIS MILLIONS OF
SUPPORTERS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
IT IS A SPEECH HE IS D
UBBING "THE POLITICAL REVOLUTION
CONTINUES."
JOINING US IS SANDERS CAMPAIGN
MANAGER JEFF WEAVER.
GREAT TO BE WITH YOU, OR TO HAVE
YOU.
HI, HOW IS IT GOING?
JEFF: DOING WELL, THINGS ARE
GOING GREAT.
JOHN: FABULOUS.
CAN YOU GIVES A PREVIEW OF WHAT
SENATOR SANDERS IS LIKELY TO SAY
OTHER THAN THE POLITICAL
REVOLUTION CONTINUES?
JEFF: IT IS A CONTINUATION OF
WHAT HE SAID ON SUNDAY WHEN HE
MET WITH PROMINENT SUPPORTERS
AND SURROGATES TALKING ABOUT HOW
WE MOVE A PROGRESSIVE AGENDA
FORWARD, HOW WOULD TRANSFORM
AMERICA.
HIS PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN IS AND
ALWAYS HAS BEEN ABOUT HOW WE
TRANSFORM AMERICA, NOT REALLY
ABOUT HIM.
I STARTED TO WORK WITH HIM 30
YEARS AGO THIS MONTH, AND HE WAS
SAYING THE SAME THING THEN THAT
HE SAYS NOW AND HE WILL BE
SAYING IT, GOD WILLING, 30 YEARS
FROM NOW.
HOW WE MOVE FORWARD NOW TO
CREATE THE KIND OF PROGRESSIVE
CHANGE WE NEED IS REALLY THE
CHALLENGE.
THAT IS WHAT HE IS TALKING ABOUT
TONIGHT.
JOHN: AGAIN, UNDERSTANDING ALL
OF THAT, TANGIBLE STEPS SHE IS
GOING TO LAY OUT -- HE IS GOING
TO LAY OUT?
JEFF: I THINK HE WILL.
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM
TO TALK TO THE MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE WHO VOTED FOR
HIM DIRECTLY UNFILTERED.
I THINK IT WILL BE A VERY
POSITIVE AND UPLIFTING SPEECH,
AND I THINK WELL RECEIVED BY THE
PEOPLE WHO WORKED HARD ON THIS
CAMPAIGN AND SUPPORTED HIM.
ALEX: JEFF KAMAL EXPECTING HER
HERE.
CAN YOU TELL US A LITTLE --
JEFF, ALEX WAGNER HERE.
CAN YOU TELL US MORE ABOUT THE
MEETING BETWEEN BERNIE SANDERS
AND HILLARY CLINTON AND ANYTHING
THAT TRANSPIRED THAT MIGHT MOVE
SENATOR SANDERS CLOSER TO
ENDORSING HILLARY CLINTON?
JEFF: WELL, I THINK IT WAS A
VERY POSITIVE MEETING, VERY
CORDIAL.
OF COURSE, THE TWO OF THEM KNOW
EACH OTHER, THEY SERVED IN THE
SENATE TOGETHER.
THERE WAS A LOT OF SUBSTANCE,
TALK ABOUT SUBSTANTIVE POLICY
ISSUES.
THEY ARE BOTH KIND OF WONKISH,
FRANKLY, AND THEY TALKED ABOUT
ISSUES WHERE THEY ARE CLOSE AND
SOME OF THE ISSUES WHERE THEY
ARE NOT SO CLOSE.
IT FOCUSED MUCH MORE ON
SUBSTANTIVE POLICY THAT PROCESS
ISSUES.
ALTHOUGH THERE WAS TALK ABOUT
REFORMING THE ELECTORAL PROCESS,
REFORMING THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY,
AND MAKING IT MORE INCLUSIVE AND
BROADENING ITS BASE.
JOHN: JEFF, ONE OF THE THINGS
YOU WILL HAVE BEEN SAYING AND
SENATOR SANDERS HAS BEEN SAYING
PRETTY CONSISTENTLY SINCE THE
DAYS OF VOTING STOPPED IN THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINATION FIGHT IS
THAT YOU WERE GOING TO CONTINUE
THE CAMPAIGN ON TO THE
CONVENTION.
JUST TELL ME, WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN?
JEFF: WELL, WHAT IT MEANS IS,
LOOK, THERE IS A PROGRESSIVE
AGENDA HE LAID OUT.
THE COUNTRY HAS A LOT OF NEEDS.
THOSE NEEDS HAVE NOT CHANGED
JUST BECAUSE THE VOTING HAS
STOPPED.
HIS LIFE'S WORK HAS BEEN TO
ADVANCE THOSE AGENDA ITEMS,
DEALING WITH INCOME INEQUALITY,
DEALING WITH A CORRUPT CAMPAIGN
FINANCE SYSTEM, GETTING HEALTH
CARE TO EVERYBODY, MAKING THE
COUNTRY A MORE FAIR AND
EQUITABLE PLACE.
THOSE ISSUES STILL EXIST.
AND THE NEEDS AND DESIRES OF THE
PEOPLE WHO SUPPORTED HIM AND THE
PEOPLE WHO DIDN'T SUPPORT HIM
STILL EXIST.
HE IS GOING TO CONTINUE WORKING
ON THAT THROUGH THE CONVENTION.
JOHN: JEFF, DOES HE INTENDED TO
CHALLENGE HER OF THE CONVENTION,
OR ARE YOU JUST TALKING ABOUT
HIM CONTINUING TO ADVOCATE ABOUT
THE ISSUES HE HAS ALWAYS CARED
ABOUT?
THERE IS A LOT OF VAGUENESS IN
"CONTINUE MY CAMPAIGN UNTIL THE
CONVENTION."
IS HE STILL TRIED TO WIN THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINATION?
JEFF: WELL, I THINK YOU WILL SEE
OF THE CONVENTION WE WILL HAVE A
UNIFIED PARTY COMING OUT OF IT,
THERE WILL BE DISCUSSION OF THE
SUBSTANTIVE ISSUES INCLUDING THE
ISSUES THAT SEPARATE THE
CANDIDATES.
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE
ISSUES TO BE AIRED AND FOR THE
RANK-AND-FILE OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY TO ADJUST POSITIONS.
JOHN: JEFF, HIS CAMPAIGN WAS TO
WIN THE DEMOCRATIC NOMINATION.
IS HE STILL CAMPAIGN TO WIN THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINATION OR NOT?
JEFF: WELCOME HE STILL IS A
CANDIDATE FOR THE DEMOCRATIC
NOMINATION.
ALEX: IS THE CAMPAIGN MAKING
CALLS TO SUPERDELEGATES?
JEFF: WE ARE NOT CURRENTLY
LOBBYING SUPERDELEGATES, WE ARE
NOT,.
JOHN: DO YOU HAVE ANY
EXTRICATION YOU WILL START
LOBBYING SUPERDELEGATES?
JEFF: I DO NOT ANTICIPATE THAT
WILL START ANYTIME SOON.
JOHN: GO AHEAD.
ALEX: IS DEBBIE WASSERMAN
TO REMF
THE DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL
COMMITTEE?
JEFF: YOU SAW IT WIDELY REPORTED
THAT THERE IS A NEW CHIEF OF
STAFF DAY-TO-DAY OPERATIONS.
THAT IS A POSITIVE STEP
FORWARD.
AS YOU KNOW, OUR CAMPAIGN AND
MILLIONS OF SUPPORTERS HAVE FELT
THAT DEBBIE WASSERMAN SCHULTZ
HAS NOT BEEN AN HONEST BROKER IN
THIS PROCESS, THAT SHE HAS LED
TO MORE DIVISION IN THE PARTY.
IS REALLY NOT IN THE POSITION TO
OFFER THE LEADERSHIP WE NEED TO
BRING THE PARTY TOGETHER IN THE
FALL.
ALEX: IS THAT A YES OR A NO?
JEFF: [LAUGHS]
I DON'T KNOW IF SHE WILL REMAIN
ON AS A TITULAR HEAD OR NOT, BUT
THE FACT IS THAT THE DAY-TO-DAY
OPERATIONS HAVE BEEN PUT IN 70
ELSE'S HANDS IS A POSITIVE SIGN
FOR THE PARTY.
JOHN: WAIT A SECOND, ARE YOU
TRYING TO SAY THAT THE MOVE
TODAY MEANS THAT DEBBIE
WASSERMAN SCHULTZ IS NO LONGER
THE EFFECTIVE CHAIRWOMAN OF THE
DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL COMMITTEE?
JEFF: WELL, I JUST READ THE NEWS
COVERAGE AND I CANNOT TELL YOU
MORE THAN THAT.
BUT HE DID SAY THAT DATA THE
OPERATIONS HAVE BEEN TURNED INTO
SOMETHING ELSE.
JOHN: LET ME PUT IT THIS WAY --
YOU GUYS HAVE SENT IN THE PAST
THAT ONE OF THE CONDITIONS
PRESENTED ARE CENTERS ULTIMATELY
ENDORSING SECRETARY CLINTON IS
THAT DEBBIE WASSERMAN SCHULTZ BE
REMOVED, CORRECT?
JEFF: WELL, HE CERTAINLY HAS
ADVOCATED FOR HER REMOVAL.
JOHN:  RIGHT, SO IS THAT
PART -- ACTUALLY, THE PRECURSOR
QUESTION FROM ISRAEL REMOVAL
PART OF WHAT HE WANTS IN ORDER
TO EVENTUALLY COME AROUND TO
SUPPORT AND SECRETARY CLINTON,
YES OR NO?
JEFF: WELL, I WOULDN'T DRAW THE
CONNECTION POINTS OR DIRECTORY
BUT HE ARTICULATED IN HIS PRESS
CONFERENCE, THE FIRST ITEM HE
TALKED ABOUT WAS THE
CHAIRWOMAN'S LEADERSHIP AND THE
FACT THAT IN ORDER TO BRING THIS
PARTY TOGETHER, WE NEED
LEADERSHIP AT THE DNC THAT CAN
YOU NAME IT -- THAT CAN UNITE
THE PARTY, THAT IS NOT SEEN AS
DIVISIVE, AND THAT CAN DO WHAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE TO HAVE
HARMONIOUS CONVENTION.
JOHN: DOES A NEW CHIEF OF STAFF
SATISFY YOU?
IF THERE IS A NEW CHIEF OF STAFF
HANDLING DAY-TO-DAY OPERATIONS,
YOU DON'T MIND IF SHE STAYS AS
TITULAR HEAD OF THE PARTY?
JEFF: WE WOULD PREFER THAT SHE
BE REMOVED OR STEP DOWN.
I THINK THIS POINT THAT IS THE
BEST COURSE FOR THE PARTY.
I FIND IT HARD TO BELIEVE THAT
AT THE CONVENTION THERE WON'T BE
HUNDREDS FOR A COUPLE THOUSAND
PEOPLE BOOING WHEN SHE COMES ON
STAGE, DESPITE OUR EFFORTS TO
MAKE SURE THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN.
ALEX: IS THE REMOVAL OF DEBBIE
WASSERMAN SCHULTZ MORE OR LESS
IMPORTANT THAN THE REFORMATION
OF THE NOMINATION PROCESS, THE
DEMOCRATIC SESSION
SUPERDELEGATES, THE LIGHT?
JEFF: WELL, THEY ARE ALL
IMPORTANT, AND SUPERDELEGATES IS
AN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT ISSUE
AND IT IS ALL PART OF PARCEL OF
TRANSFORMING THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
HE NEEDS TO BE OPENED UP, HE
NEEDS TO HAVE A GRASSROOTS FOCUS
, AND DEBBIE WASSERMAN SCHULTZ
IS NOT REALLY THE PERSON TO DO
THAT.
JOHN: JEFF, LET ME PUT IT TO YOU
THIS WAY.
THERE ARE A VARIETY OF THINGS
THAT YOU GUYS ARE FOR.
THERE IS THINGS ON POLICY WHERE
YOU HAVE DIFFERENCES WITH
SECRETARY CLINTON.
THERE IS THINGS IN THE PLATFORM.
THERE IS PROCESS REFORMS,
INCLUDING SAME-DAY REGISTRATION,
OPEN PRIMARIES, AND OF
SUPERDELEGATES.
ARE ALL OF THOSE -- AND MY
DESCRIBING ALL OF THOSE THINGS
DO YOU, IS IT FAIR TO SAY THAT
THOSE ARE ALL THINGS YOU ARE
TRYING TO NEGOTIATE WITH THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN AS SOME KIND OF
PACKAGE THAT WOULD LEAD SENATOR
SANDERS TO ENDORSE SECRETARY
CLINTON?
JEFF: I THINK IT IS FAIR TO SAY
THAT ALL THOSE ISSUES ARE UNDER
DISCUSSION AT THE CAMPAIGN, THE
STAFF LEVEL AND THE OTHER NIGHT
AMONG THE PRINCIPALS.
YES, WE ARE DISCUSSING THOSE
ISSUES.
JOHN: RIGHT, BUT YOU ARE SAYING
THAT NOT ALL OF THEM ARE
NONNEGOTIABLE -- OBVIOUS THE,
YOU ARE IN NEGOTIATIONS.
BUT IF SECRETARY CLINTON GIVES
ON SOME OF THOSE ISSUES AND YOU
GUYS FIND A MUTUALLY AGREEABLE
SET OF CONCESSIONS, SO TO SPEAK,
THAT THAT WILL THEN LEADS TO
SENATOR SANDERS ENDORSING
SECRETARY CLINTON BEFORE THE
CONVENTION?
IS THAT TRUE OR FALSE?
JEFF: I WOULDN'T DESCRIBE THEM
AS CONCESSIONS.
WHAT I WOULD SAY THAT ALMOST 12
MILLION PEOPLE VOTED FOR BERNIE
SANDERS, HE WON 23 CONTESTS.
THERE IS A HUGE PART OF THE
DEMOCRATIC BASE THAT SUPPORTED
HIS AGENDA AND THE REFORMS THAT
HE WANTS TO ENACT, AND I THINK
IT IS BEST FOR THE PARTY IF THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN ACKNOWLEDGES
THAT REALITY AND REACHES OUT TO
THOSE VOTERS WITH TANGIBLE,
CONCRETE CHANGES THAT WILL LET
THOSE PEOPLE KNOW THAT THEIR
VOICE HAS BEEN HEARD IN THIS
PROCESS.
JOHN: LET ME REMOVE THE WORD
"CONCESSIONS" AND COME BACK TO
THE ORIGINAL QUESTION.
IF YOU GUYS REACH A PACKAGE OF
CHANGES, SOME OF WHICH SHE WILL
AGREE TO, SOME OF WHICH SHE MAY
NOT AGREE TO -- AGAIN, NOT
SUGGESTING YOU ARE SAYING ALL OF
THESE ARE NONNEGOTIABLE, YOU
MUST HAVE XYZ, BUT IF YOU GUYS
REACH AN AGREEMENT ON SOME
CHANGES TAKING PLACE, THE RESULT
OF THAT WILL BE SENATOR SANDERS
ENDORSING SECRETARY POSITION
BEFORE THE CONVENTION, YES OR
NO?
JEFF: WELL MY WOULD SAY THAT THE
PARTY WILL BE UNIFIED.
SENATOR SANDERS HAS ALWAYS SAID
HE WOULD SUPPORT THE DEMOCRATIC
NOMINEE.
SO I THINK AFTER THAT
CONVERSATION, BOTH WITH THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN AND WITH OUR
SUPPORTERS, WE WOULD LIKE TO GET
TO A PLACE WHERE WE COULD VERY
ACTIVELY SUPPORT THE NOMINEE.
JOHN: RIGHT, AND THAT NOMINEES
SECRETARY CLINTON IN THIS CASE?
YOU HAVE BASICALLY CONCEDED, YOU
ARE NOT SWITCHING SUPERDELEGATES
WAS, YOU ARE NOT -- YOU HAVE NO
PLANS TO DO THAT, AND YOU ARE
TRY TO GET TO THE POINT WHERE
YOU CAN BE BEHIND HER?
JEFF: WELL, CERTAINLY SHE HAS
BEEN CALLED THE PRESUMPTIVE OMNI
BY THE MEDIA, THAT IS FOR SURE.
JOHN: UM --
[LAUGHS]
BUT I'M ASKING YOU, JEFF.
JEFF: I KNOW YOU ARE.
JOHN: YOU ARE NOT DOING THE
THINGS THAT WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
MAKE HIM THE NOMINEE, IE
FLIPPING SUPERDELEGATES, AND YOU
HAVE A SET OF NEGOTIATIONS THAT
YOU ARE ESSENTIALLY THINK ARE A
PRICE FOR HIS SUPPORT.
IS THERE -- IS THERE ANYTHING I
SAID YOU KNOW THAT IS UNTRUE?
JEFF: I THINK IT SPEAKS FOR
ITSELF, JOHN.
ALEX: JEFF, THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN
-- HOW WOULD YOU CHARACTERIZE
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE TWO
CAMPAIGNS AT THIS POINT?
JEFF: OH, I THINK THE
RELATIONSHIP IS VERY GOOD.
STAFF CONTACTS HAVE BEEN
FREQUENT AND FRIENDLY.
I THINK WE ARE DIGGING DOWN INTO
THE WEEDS ON A NUMBER OF ISSUES.
THE MEETING BETWEEN THE SENATOR
AT THE SECRETARY WAS VERY GOOD.
I THINK PEOPLE ARE WORKING
TOGETHER BECAUSE THEY UNDERSTAND
THAT WE NEED TO DEFEAT DONALD
TRUMP IN THE FALL.
THAT IS IN IMPERATIVE.
JOHN: JEFF, THANK YOU FOR COMING
ON, THANK YOU FOR MAKING, I
BELIEVE, A LITTLE BIT OF NEWS.
JEFF: I DON'T THINK I MADE ANY
NEWS.
I NEVER MAKE NEWS.
JOHN: THAT'S ALL YOU EVER DO IS
MAKING NEWS!
YOU ALSO LOOK FOR MARKEDLY
HEALTHY.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT IS TAN OR
GOOD LENGTH.
JEFF -- GOOD LIGHTING.
JEFF: NO MAKEUP.
ALEX: I WILL HAVE WHAT HE'S
HAVING.
JOHN: COMING UP, THE ONE AND
ONLY DANCING OR, INFORMAL
ADVISOR TO PAUL RYAN, TALKING
ABOUT DONALD TRUMP AFTER THIS
WORD FROM OUR SPONSORS.
JOHN: RIGHT HERE WITH US IN
STUDIO WE HAVE DAN SENOR,
INFORMAL ADVISOR TO PAUL RYAN
AND OTHERS, AND ALEX CONANT.
ALEX HAS BEEN WAITING TO SEE YOU
ALL DAY LONG.
ALEX: I NEEDED ANOTHER ALEX AS
BACKUP.
JOHN: WE WERE SPEAKING OF PAUL
RYAN AND I THOUGHT IN AN
INFORMED WAY THAT THE SPEAKER
WAS LEAVING THE DOOR WIDE OPEN
--
DAN: WIDE OPEN.
JOHN: TWO RESCINDING HIS
ADJUSTMENT OF DONALD TRUMP.
IS THAT TRUE?
DAN: I THINK IT IS SAFE TO SAY
THAT A LOT OF REPUBLICAN LEADERS
ARE NOT TERRIBLY ENTHUSIASTIC
ABOUT THE REBOOT OF THE TRUNK
CANDIDACY OVER THE LAST FEW DAYS
, AND SO THEY ARE BEING RESERVED
IN HOW THEY EXPRESS THEIR
ENTHUSIASM ABOUT HIS CANDIDACY.
WHETHER HE IS LEAVING THE DOOR
OPEN A LITTLE BIT, A LOT, NOT AT
ALL, NOT TO SPECULATE.
I'M JUST TELLING YOU I'M NOT
SURPRISED BY HOW RESTRAINED YOU
ARE HEARING --
JOHN: BUT YOU KNOW THE SPEAKER
PRETTY WELL.
DO YOU THINK THERE IS A LIVE
OPTION?
DAN: NOT NOW.
I TAKE HIM AT HIS WORD.
JOHN: I UNDERSTAND MY
UNDERSTANDIN -- I UNDERSTAND, I
UNDERSTAND.
DAN: HE SAID IT IS NOT SOMETHING
I INTEND TO DO SO IT IS NOT HE
IS CONTEMPLATING.
THEY HAVE ENDORSED TRUMP, THEY
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT HIS CAMPAIGN
AND THE DOWN BALLOT COLLATERAL
DAMAGE.
ALEX W.: ARE THEY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE DAMAGE A TRUMP
ENDORSEMENT MIGHT WREAK ON THEIR
OWN PERSONAL FORTUNES?
PAUL RYAN IS SEEN AS THE HOPE OF
THE PARTY IN 2020 AND BEYOND.
ARE THEY MAKING A PERSONAL
CALCULATION?
DAN: AT THIS POINT IN TERMS OF
HOW TO THINK ABOUT TRUMP, I'VE
TALKED TO HIM QUITE A BIT.
I'M VERY CRITICAL OF TRUMP AND
WHAT I SAY IS NOT REFLECTIVE OF
WHAT HE THINKS.
BUT ONE OF THE FACTORS FOR HIM
IS THAT HE BELIEVES IF HOUSE
REPUBLICANS ARE DIVIDED, IT
WOULD -- EVEN IF THEY THINK THAT
THINGS TRUMP IS IT SAYING ARE
REPREHENSIBLE, IT WOULD DO MORE
DAMAGE TO THE CHANCES OF
REPUBLICANS TAKING THE MAJORITY
THAT IF THEY WERE AT WORK AT
EACH OTHER OVER TRUMP.
JOHN: ALEX CONANT, NOT ALEX
WAGNER, DO YOU THINK THE
REPUBLICANS HAVE REACHED THE
CONCLUSION -- I'VE HEARD YOU
SAYING THAT TRUMP NEEDS TO
CHANGE, THE MORE PRESIDENTIAL.
HAVE YOU GIVEN THAT UP NOW?
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN: A LOT OF REPUBLICANS ARE
SAYING THAT IS A LOST CAUSE.
ALEX C.: LOSING HOPE IS PROBABLY
THE RIGHT WAY TO LOOK AT IT.
DONALD TRUMP, HE IS GOING TO WIN
THIS FALL, NEEDS TO HAVE A
CAMPAIGN AROUND IN THE HEAT
CIRCUITS -- HE NEEDS CIRCUITS
FOR HIS MESSAGE AGAINST THE
CLINTON MACHINE.
IT IS TROUBLING THAT WE ARE NOT
TAKEN AFFIRMATIVE STEPS TOWARDS
PUTTING TOGETHER THE KIND OF
CAMPAIGN HE NEEDS NOT JUST TO
WIN BUT JUST TO HAVE IT BE CLOSE
THIS FALL.
THE TRAJECTORY IN THE POLLS IS
VERY TROUBLING AND IF I AM
DONALD TRUMP, I'M WORRIED ABOUT
IT.
ALEX W.: BUT, ALEX, WHEN WE HEAR
PARTY ELDERS AND STRATEGISTS AND
RELATED FOLKS SAYING THAT TRUMP
NEEDS TO GET ON MESSAGE AND DO
XYZ, ONE MIGHT SAY TRUMP NEEDS
DESCRIBED THINGS AND DO SEVERAL
OTHER THINGS THAT WILL NEVER
NATURALLY HAVE BEEN GIVEN THIS
MASTER JEFFREY S FAR AS THIS MAN
-- THIS MAN'S TRAJECTORY BEST
PART.
WHAT REASON IS THERE TO HOPE
THAT HE WILL DO THESE REFORMS IN
A TIMELY FASHION?
ALEX C.: BECAUSE HE WANTS TO
WIN.
ALEX W.: DO YOU BELIEVE HE NEEDS
TO CHANGE IN ORDER TO WIN?
ALEX C.: WE ARE GOING TO TEST
THAT PROPOSITION.
WE ARE ABOUT TO FIND THAT OUT.
AS OF TODAY HE ONLY HAS ONE OF
TWO COMMUNICATORS ON THE WHOLE
CAMPAIGN AND THEY ARE DOING
HUMANS WORK COULD I HAD WANTED
TO STEP AS LAST SUMMER ON THE
RUBIO CAMPAIGN -- ONE OR TWO
STAFFERS LAST SUMMER ON THE
RUBIO CAMPAIGN AND WE WERE
STRUGGLING.
I CAN ONLY IMAGINE WHAT TRUMP'S
COMMUNICATORS ARE DEALING WITH.
DAN: VIRTUALLY NO COMMUNICATION
WITH THE RNC.
CONTINUING TO SAY INCREDIBLY
INFLAMMATORY THINGS.
NOT TO MEETING WITH REPUBLICAN
ELECTED LEADERS.
-- NOT INDICATING WITH
REPUBLICAN ELECTED LEADERS.
EVERYTHING HE HAS DONE IN THIS
ELECTION AND EVERYTHING HE HAS
DONE IN HIS CAREER, HE HAS HAD
ONE SPEED.
THE IDEA THAT HE WILL SUDDENLY
START LOOKING AND BEHEADING
PRESIDENTIAL --
JOHN: AS YOU POINTED OUT, YOU
WERE OUT FRONT, NEVER TRUMP, #NE
VERTRUMP.
YOU ARE ALSO PRETTY MUCH
#DUMPTRUMP AT THIS POINT.
YOU ARE WORKING BEHIND THE
SCENES TO KEEP HIM FROM BEING
THE NOMINEE OF THE PARTY,
CORRECT?
DAN: THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
PEOPLE BRAINSTORMING ON WHETHER
OR NOT WE CAN CAPITALIZE RIGHT
NOW -- I LEAVE WE ARE AT A BIT
OF AN INFLECTION POINT.
RIGHT NOW THERE IS GENUINE
CONCERN AMONG REPUBLICANS,
REPUBLICAN ELECTED LEADERS,
DONORS, AND ACTIVISTS, AND MANY
DELEGATES WHO ARE ATTENDING THE
CONVENTION -- BY THE WAY, IT IS
DIRECTLY CORRELATED WITH TRUMP'S
COLLAPSING POLYMERS.
THERE IS A RELATION BETWEEN THE
TOLERANCE OF THE INSANE THINGS
TRUMP DOES AND THE WAY HE
BEHAVES AND GOOD POLYMERS.
NOW PEOPLE ARE SAYING THAT THIS
COULD BE A REAL MESS SO THERE
ARE DISCUSSIONS ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT HE COULD BE DISLODGED AT THE
CONVENTION.
WHETHER OR NOT IT WILL GET
TOGETHER IN THE NEXT COUPLE
WEEKS --
JOHN: OR WHETHER IT WILL BE AS
SUCCESSFUL AS REFERENCE IN THE
NEVER TRUMP MOVEMENT.
[LAUGHTER]
DAN: HEY, COME ON!
JOHN: WHAT PERCENTAGE LIKELIHOOD
THAT TRUMP WILL BE THE NOMINEE?
DAN: OH, I WOULD SAY 80-PLUS
PERCENT.
ALEX C.: THESE THINGS REACH A
TIPPING POINT WHERE HAVING
CHANGES OVERNIGHT.
IT IS GOING TO HAPPEN VERY
QUICKLY IF IT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
THERE WILL BE A MOMENT WHERE THE
SPORT FOR HIM CLASSES AND THE
POLITICAL UNIVERSE LOOKS VERY
DIFFERENT.
SIX WEEKS FROM HERE TO CLEVELAND
, THAT IS A LONG, LONG TIME IN
PRESIDENTIAL POLITICS AND A LOT
AND CHANGE.
ALEX W.: AND YET YOU LOOK AT THE
NUMBERS AND GENERAL AMERICAN
APPROVAL FOR EACH PARTY AND
REPUBLICAN NUMBERS ARE NOT I'M
SURE WHERE THE PARTY WANTED TO
BE, THE APPROVAL NUMBERS.
ARE THERE CONVERSATIONS
HAPPENING IN REPUBLICAN CIRCLES
ABOUT  NOVEMBER AND WHAT HAPPENS
AFTER NOVEMBER TO THE PARTY --
ALEX C.: I THINK PEOPLE ARE
STILL FOCUSED ON NOVEMBER.
I AM OLD ENOUGH TO REMEMBER IN
1992 FROM ONE OF THE PEOPLE
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT, HE WAS A
SELF-FUNDED BILLIONAIRE, AND AT
THIS POINT HE LOOKED VERY VIABLE
TO SIX WEEKS LATER HE DROPPED
OUT OF THE RACE.
ROSS PEROT.
ALEX W.: DO YOU THINK ROSS PEROT
IS AN APPROPRIATE ANALOG?
ALEX C.: I'M JUST SAYING A LOT
CAN HAPPEN AT THE CONVENTION AND
BETWEEN NOW AND THE CONVENTION.
THE ONUS IS ON TRUMP TO SHOW
THAT HE IS CAPABLE OF PUTTING
TOGETHER A CAMPAIGN THAT CAN BE
COMPETITIVE FALL.
JOHN: WHAT DONALD TRUMP WITH IT
TO BOTH OF YOU IS BE QUIET.
[LAUGHTER]
ALEX W.: BETTER THAN "YOU'RE
FIRED."
DAN: IT'S NOT OVER!
JOHN: DAN SENOR, ALEX CONANT,
ALEX WAGNER, THANK YOU, ALL
THREE OF YOU.
COMING UP, DONALD TRUMP, A MAN
OF MANY  WORDS.
YOU CAN LISTEN TO US ON THE
REGULAR RADIO, 99.1 FM.
WE WILL BE RIGHT BACK.
JOHN: AS YOU WILL KNOW, TODAY IS
A HUGE MILESTONE MOMENT IN THE
POLITICAL WORLD.
EXACTLY ONE YEAR AGO TODAY,
DONALD J TRUMP DISSENTED AND
ESCALATOR IN TRUMP TOWER TO
ANNOUNCE HIS RESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN.
BETWEEN THEN AND NOW HE HAS SENT
A WHOLE LOT OF THINGS, SO WE
DECIDED TO TAKE A LOOK BACK AT
TRUMP'S HUGE, UNPREDICTABLE
YEAR, ONE WORD AT A TIME.
MR. TRUMP: MEXICO.
RAPING.
POLLS.
ANDREW BAILEY. -- ANCHOR BABY.
THE BIBLE.
WINNING.
[BLEEP]
MOLESTER.
MUSLIMS.
CURRENT THINGS.
[BLEEP]
RUBIO!
BRAIN.
POLLS.
PUNISHMENT.
RETWEET.
CRAZY.
POCAHONTAS.
CONGRATULATIONS.
RADICAL.
BIGLY.
JOHN: SO NOW, ALEX, I HAVE A
QUESTION FOR YOU.
WHAT IS YOUR ONE-WORD RESPONSE
TO THAT?
ALEX W.: YOU ARE PUTTING ME ON
THE SPOT TO ANSWER THAT?
I WOULD JUST ECHO TRUMP AND SAY
HUGE.
THAT WAS A MASSIVE WORK OF THE
VIDEO ARE RIGHT THERE.
JOHN: IT IS EPIC.
ALEX W.: HE HAS FOREVER CHANGED
AMERICAN POLITICS, JOHN.
JOHN: SO, SO FEW OF THOSE WORDS
I EVER THOUGHT I WOULD HEAR.
ALEX W.: "BIGLY."
NOT A WORD!
JOHN: VERY FEW OF THEM --
ALEX W.: YOU DON'T NEED TO WORRY
ABOUT CONTEXT, SYNTAX,
SUBJECT-FOR AGREEMENT.
JOHN: WE WILL BE RIGHT BACK WITH
A BIGLY CLOSE OF THE SHOW.
JOHN: A BIG THANK YOU TO "THE
ATLANTIC'S" ALEXANDER.
-- ALEX WAGNER.
ALEX W.: ALWAYS A PLEASURE TO BE
HERE, MY FRIEND.
JOHN: COMING UP ON BLOOMBERG TV,
JEREMY JOHNSON, THAT'S ON
"BLOOMBERG WEST."
FOR ME AND YOU CAN UNTIL
TOMORROW, WE HAD THIS TO SAY.
ALEX W.: NAMASTE.
♪
>> LET'S START WITH THE CHECK OF
YOUR NEWS.
PRESIDENT OBAMA IS IN ORLANDO
TODAY, COMFORTING THE SURVIVORS
AND FAMILY OF VICTIMS.
PRESIDENT OBAMA: THEY ARE PART
OF OUR FAMILY, THE AMERICAN
FAMILY.
TODAY, VICE PRESIDENT AND I TOLD
THEM, ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, THAT OUR HEARTS ARE
BROKEN TOO.
REPORTER: THE PRESIDENT ALSO
PLEADED FOR CONGRESS TO CONSIDER
GUN CONTROL MEASURES.
U.K. POLICE SAY A BRITISH MEMBER
OF PARLIAMENT HAS DIED AFTER
BEING ATTACKED.
SHE WAS MEETING WITH
CONSTITUENTS AND REST -- IN WEST
YORKSHIRE WHEN SHE WAS SHOT
TWICE.
THE SUSPECT HAS BEEN ARRESTED.
CAMPAIGNING HAS BEEN SUSPENDED
ON THE REFERENDUM ON THE
EUROPEAN UNION.
INVESTIGATORS SAY IMAGE 370'S
VOICE RECORDER HAS BEEN PULLED
FROM THE MEDITERRANEAN SEA.
THE MEMORY UNIT IS INTACT.